a lot of people are living life
aimlessly wanting things and not getting
them and sometimes feeling like they
have success and sometimes feeling like
they don't and it's this sort of yo-yo
of up and down it's such a frantic way
of living and we don't know how to tune
in and get connected to having a life
that flows
difference between being aligned and
being misaligned when we are aligned
with the truth of who we are that is
when our life begins to flow when we're
misaligned we're controlling we're
speaking really fast we're trying to
make things happen we're feeling
uncomfortable in all these different
situations and we're trying to force
something and we're trying to manipulate
and that misaligned feeling feels like a
depressing feeling or a feeling of
anxiety and it feels really blocked so I
want to get you clear on what it feels
like to be in alignment how to get there
and how to use that alignment to start
to create the flow that you want in your
life Hey Kevin Carmichael and I make
these videos because in my first
business I was making 300 bucks a month
I quit on my business partner and the
thing that saved me was studying the
stories of super successful
entrepreneurs so I hope that this story
today helps give you the motivation you
need because I still needed to myself so
today let's live your best believe life
and learn how to attract anything into
your life enjoy
let me give you an example from my own
life of how I recently got very
misaligned I was launching one of my
books and I was very stressed out I had
a story on repeat if I don't do it
nobody else will and that story made me
anxious it made me stressed and what it
did in effect was create a world around
me where nobody else could support me
because I didn't believe they would and
what we believe we will receive so that
frantic energy that negative story all
those fears were putting me in a state
of misalignment and the way that I felt
when I was misaligned was depressed sick
anxious my stomach hurt all the time I
felt like I was constantly in a fight or
flight state
that energy is the opposite of a flowing
energy
the first step to clearing this issue is
to recognize when you're in alignment
and when you're misaligned at the end of
my book tour I was so burnt out I was
sick I was super frustrated I had
created some really negative issues with
my relationships and everything was
completely out of the flow
and this one night I stood in front of
my husband and I just realized that I
had hit bottom with my misalignment and
I looked at my husband and I said I am
done with this I am done with the story
that I am unsupported and I am committed
to feeling good
that one sentence I am committed to
feeling good was a prayer that I sent
out to the universe and that willingness
and that commitment and that story is
what begins the path of shifting from
misalignment back into alignment it's a
choice you make it's as simple as that
what I did in that moment was I chose to
perceive my circumstances differently
and this is what I call the choose again
method the first step is to witness to
look to say whoa I am out of alignment
get very clear and honest with yourself
what is up how am I blocking my flow the
second step is to forgive the thoughts
and the patterns and the experiences
that you've been having forgive yourself
for getting misaligned it's okay it have
happens to all of us and the faster that
you forgive yourself for it the sooner
you will come back and then the third
step is awesome you just choose again
you choose the next best feeling thought
you choose to see things differently you
choose what you want rather than what
you don't want and you claim it and you
commit to it and that energy of
committing to that new way of perceiving
your life starts to create momentum
behind you and begins to lead you
towards exactly what you desire we
deserve to feel good we deserve to see
things unfold naturally in our life and
we have to just get out of the way you
can change your energy and you can start
to see life unfold in the exact way that
you want it to so take this with you and
let's see what unfolds rule number two
is change the program with Bruce Lipton
here's important part let's just start
with this
the mind is controlling our biology
that's a fact now I go but when you say
the mind it sounds like oh there's one
mind I go now that is where it goes
wrong because there are two minds and
they they both have different functions
and most importantly they learn in
different ways what are the two minds
well let's start with the latest
Evolution right behind your forehead is
a lump of brain called prefrontal cortex
the seat of self-consciousness I am an
individual I am separate from all other
individuals I am a self and I'm you know
coming from this creative part the
subconscious mind as we mentioned that's
just the hard drive with programs in it
so I say so what's the difference
between it well the first thing is this
what makes humans so different than
other organisms is the self-conscious or
conscious mind because it's creative it
has imagination I could ask you right
now Louis I can tell you I could ask you
a question I say tell me what you want
out of your life
well at that moment you're going to
think and you're going to say you know I
want this and I want that and I go well
that came from the conscious mind now
it's creative that has imagination that
has vision and if you have a a vision
you can then manifest a vision if you
can't manifest a vision if you don't
have a vision so your conscious mind
sets up Visions in what we want
but here's the point
um and this is the the critical the
whole thing is on this one part right
now Louis right here not as this the
conscious mind which is the creative
mind versus subconscious mind which is
the Habit mind it does habits as does as
program programs I have it push the
button play the program push the button
Play It Again push it play it again okay
program conscious mind Creator okay and
I go okay significance of that is that's
where your wishes and desires are
what do you want oh man I want this I
want a great relationship I want a great
job I want great health you know you
creative
the subconscious mind programs primarily
derive from other people before age
seven okay and unfiltered so there are
good programs and there are bad programs
okay uh and I go so
creative conscious mind is the one that
gives you a destination and a future
subconscious mind just gives you
autopilot
okay back to the Crux of the problem
only five percent of the day is the
conscious mind actually an Engaged in
creating
and I go with them what's it doing 95 I
said 95 of the day it's thinking okay so
what does that mean I go imagine your
body's a vehicle steering wheel
conscious is a holding a wheel and
driving us to wear wishes and desires
man okay I say but if I start thinking
then conscious mind is no longer looking
out because thinking is inside it's a
thought on the inside I said well if
you're thinking then conscious mind is
not looking out I go well what if you're
driving the car and then you start
thinking I go
conscious mind let go of the wheel I
thought oh my God don't worry why
subconscious mind is autopilot whatever
you're not controlling with your
conscious mind subconscious mind throws
a program in and does it okay now the
issue about that is well if the
conscious mind is thinking is it
observing what's going on I go no to
observe what's going on it has to look
out the window can't be looking inside
so 95 of the day it doesn't even observe
your own behavior I said but where's
that behavior coming from I go the
program I go but yeah but where did that
come from I go somebody else
well if they didn't put your wishes and
desires into their life then you copied
their program you're you're not going
toward your wishes and desires going to
wherever their program is going to
that's how children follow in the
footpath of their parents especially
like musicians a musician who's a parent
during the programming of Their Own
Child instills them with all the music
and stuff like that then a child grows
up and guess what now they're a musician
people the music Gene I go there's no
music Jane there was training first
seven years training to be that so the
issue is
95 of our life is not coming from wishes
and desires it's coming from programs
which came from other people and you
don't see it when it's happening and I
go why not and I said why are you
playing a program because I'm not paying
attention I go well that's why you don't
see the program and I go and then 95 of
your life is programmed and then the
relevance about that is 60 of those are
disempowering or self-sabotaging or
limiting beliefs so it says then 95 of
the day you're running your life and
you're the only one that doesn't see it
I go well that's the big issue I go the
same story for 40 years that's been in
all my videos but I got to do it again
because different audience here yeah you
have a friend you know your friends
Behavior very very well you're really
you know good friends and you happen to
know your friends parent
and one day you see your friend has the
same behavior as their parents so you
know you gotta you gotta tell hey Bill
you're just like your dad back away from
Bill I know exactly what Bill's going to
say all the time Bill's going to say how
can you compare me to my dad I'm nothing
like my dad the audience laughs why
they're familiar with it I go that you
want the profound story of the day
that's the profound story I go what does
it mean everybody else can see that bill
it behaves like his dad the only one who
can't see it is Bill
explain it simple yeah
Bill downloaded these programs from his
dad yep when does he play him when he's
thinking am I saying how much of that I
say 95 of the day I say does he see the
program I say no thinking is inside he's
not working out and so Bill's the only
one that doesn't see it and he got it
from somebody else and so it's not his
behavior and he could be sabotaging
himself and he's the only one that can't
see it
because why because he's thinking and I
go okay you ready all of us are Bill
right all of us every day are Bill we're
playing the same programs we look at
life going oh man that's not what I
wanted I would oh this is not really
good and I go where's this coming from
well those people are causing this
people are causing I go
no you're the Creator didn't see what
you were creating with and when we get
personal awareness of this then personal
empowerment is the next step because now
it's like well if I'm doing this then
I'm the one that can change it I go
absolutely
absolutely that's what the whole point
is and this is why you're you know all
your programs for the wish are so
involved with wake up people it's time
to take the power back and become what
you want to be in this life because you
don't realize you're playing programs
that are sabotaging you all day long and
you don't see it you're the only one
right so that's the the big wake-up call
so it says well what can I do when I say
well hey you could just not play the
program and I go that's not easy to do
that means you can't think
it's so fundamental everything uh so
it's very difficult to say I will stay
mindful that means I will not think I
will stay here in the present mind and
pay attention to what's going on I go
great but it's very difficult to do that
so I said well if you're not going to
say mindful then what else can I do I
said well then change the program and if
you change the program then 95 of the
day if you put a program that's your
wishes and your desires then 95 of the
day you will be manifesting that when
the program is running wow plus an
additional five percent when your
conscious mind is running it's a that
would be a hundred percent of the day
you would be moving toward wishes and
desires but you have to look at the
program that's why we announced I said
what's the program
look at your life what do you want to
change what's not working for you rule
number three is be who you are with
Rhonda Byrne I think the challenge that
we think about when we think about
success or happiness we think of success
and happiness on the basis of the body
and the mind and that's why even after
accumulating everything we still feel
dissatisfied because those things only
touch the body and mind correct Rhonda
correct correct and and and really the
best thing that could happen to
everybody is that their greatest dream
comes true
because when your greatest dream comes
true the dream that where you are
absolutely convinced that when this
dream comes true that is when I will
really be happy the best thing that can
happen is that dream comes true because
when it does you will realize that there
is something missing and that happiness
that you thought you would have doesn't
last and so it's you know it's it's such
a beautiful thing and for people who
have been successful then they get to
that point and they're like they're not
happy and they're not happy because
those things were never going to make
you happy in the first place anyway and
so um but in terms of success
I would say this that
when you are who you really are when
you're living from the place more of who
you are than who you are not
everything that you need and want will
fall into your hands effortlessly and
you are actually the infinite being is
effortless
and the way to kind of tell who's in
charge is whether it's the ego or the
mind that's in charge or or who you
really are that is in charge in any
moment is effort and if you're efforting
if you can feel this efforting then it's
the ego in the mind and if you're coming
from a place of effortlessness where
athletes call it being in the flow and
everybody has these kind of descriptions
it's where the mind has stopped and just
everything is Flowing us you just feel
like everything in the universe is just
dancing your dance and singing to your
song and so in terms of success when you
are being more of Who You Are
that idea that was going to make you
successful is what will come to you that
original idea because the mind just
recycles that's all it can do it's a
program and recycles and the ideas that
business kind of business ideas that
have never been on Earth they are coming
from awareness
they are coming from above the vine so
when you are awareness that is when
everything will fall into your hands
everything that you need and it just
your whole life flows and you're just
happy all of the time like there is it's
just like the universe is just saying
and I even wrote In The Sacred you know
the shortcut to the secret is be happy
now right just be happy let go of all of
the things that that you're saying why
you can't be happy and just be happy now
because when you're happy everything
just everything just falls into place
it's so amazing so definitely for
success
that is the fastest fastest way to
success is to be who you are and
um it's not you don't we're not talking
about going in a cave or you know or
doing anything like that we are talking
about living your life in the incredible
form and human being that you are and
having the experience that you are but
from a place of knowing that you were
the infinite being that you are Immortal
and we are taught as Jay said it's got
to be through your experience it can't
be through oh I heard you know Rhonda
talk about this and whatever no not
interested in you taking on another
belief what what it is is for you to
experience it and it is not hard for you
to experience it because it's who you
are already it's not anything that you
have to go out and get in some ways it's
almost frustrating isn't it I remember
when I started out I'm like it's who I
am already but at the time you know I'd
be like I can tell the minds my mind's
taken over at the moment and yeah it's
already who we are and so we've just
what we've done is we've attributed
everything that is awareness to the Mind
we've given the mind the whole thing and
it's awareness that is hearing these
words right now
that is what's hearing these words right
that is what he's saying uh through
these eyes it's awareness it's without
awareness we wouldn't even know we're
alive also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is connect your
Consciousness to energy with Joe
dispenza have you said because now we
have evidence of about a lot of things
that your work working on the things
that you've been believing for so many
years that you knew worked for you and
you saw transformation with yourself
we're not going to go into your accident
because that's in the last interview
but now we have proof and evidence and
science backing all this and how did
that start to happen yeah it's a great
dialogue because I think this is a time
in history where it's not enough to know
this is a time in history to know how
and if you rewind the tape 10 years ago
you know information was the thing that
stimulated thought stimulated new ideas
and and as we learn new things we make
new Connections in our brains so as we
begin to add new Stitches into that
three-dimensional tapestry in our mind
we're beginning to cause our mind to
function in new ways but the key then is
to apply it to personalize it to do
something with it and in 10 years ago
when I went got in front of an audience
and talked about the application it
nobody wanted to step outside that
philosophical theoretical intellectual
realm right because doing something
means you're gonna have to change
something about yourself yeah you're
going to get uncomfortable right and
um I think we're in an age of
information
and in an age of information ignorance
is a choice and because of Technology we
have access to so much content and
information creates awareness and
awareness is consciousness and you can't
have Consciousness without energy there
they work together so there's an
energetic change I think that's taking
place in the world right now where
people are so informed that old models
old paradigms are beginning to break
down whether it's the medical model or
the religious model the educational
model journalism uh the economy you know
politics it's all beginning to come to
the surface because something else has
to come out and and I think that one of
the things that people are realizing is
that you don't have to be a Buddhist
monk to do this or a nun with 40 Years
of devotion you just got to understand
the formula and just like any skill or
anything you learn
you got to go from thinking to doing to
being you got to take knowledge you
create the experience and if you keep
doing it over and over again you start
getting a skill or you start getting
wise about how to do it and you you know
that you know how to do it well
in the last 10 years we have assembled
the scientific team and let's see if you
can really make significant brain
changes I don't want those changes to
just be in your mind
I want them to be in your brain I want
to be able to see before and after
pictures to say that person has a
significant change after a traumatic
brain injury or anxiety or depression or
a cyclic mood disorder or a stroke we
want to see that there's been
significant change at the same time
let's measure your brain in real time
and let's look to see what that
transformation process looks like and in
the discovery Lewis of that process
we gained so much knowledge about what
that transformational process looks like
in other words I can tell you without a
doubt that if you're analyzing your life
right now within some disturbing emotion
that 100 of the time you're going to
make your brain worse when you think
about your life if you're stuck in an
emotion like you're frustrated you're
angry or fearful resentful resentful and
you're thinking within that emotional
state in other words you can't think
greater than how you feel
that means then you were thinking in the
past because those emotions are a record
or residue of the past so we see people
in the in the process of change that
aren't analyzing and uh in in Duality or
polarity that kind of drives the brain
into higher states of arousal and and
further away from True change so
we did we've done thousands and
thousands and thousands of brain scans
and and we now know that there's a
formula to create greater brain
coherence greater brain efficiency to
make your brain work better and when
your brain works better you work better
at the same time
it requires a clear intention and an
elevated emotion to begin to change your
energy and to change your life and
nobody changes until they change their
energy right so then how do you get a
person out of resentment frustration
into joy and freedom if why would they
feel grateful or joyful or free if the
experience hasn't happened so most
people are spending the majority of
their life waiting for something out
there to take away their emptiness or
pain or the resentment in here well
if they're they're waiting their whole
life in separation or lack then and and
we create reality then the lack is
driving certain thoughts which is
creating more separation and more lacks
so teaching people then to begin to
condition their body emotionally before
the evidence takes place in their life
is breaking a significant habit right so
instead of living by cause and effect
now we're beginning to cause an effect
so the moment you start feeling whole
and grateful we now know your healing
will begin at that moment yes the moment
you start feeling
um worthy and abundant your wealth is
coming you know you're generating a
certain amount of energy a certain
amount of wealth and so how does someone
feel worthy though if they've always
been told they're not worth it yeah well
so
let me oh that's the story they tell
themselves yeah like I'm not worth it
because yeah she didn't say yes when I
asked her on a date right because he
broke up with me because I got fired
because my parents left me how do they
how am I worth it when there's so much
evidence or story around a negative well
thing let's stop telling the story of
your past and let's start telling the
story of your future and and people who
aren't defined by a vision of the future
for the most part are left with memories
of the past that your brain is a record
of the past it's an artifact of
everything you've learned and
experienced at this moment so most
people wake up in the morning and
they start thinking about their problems
yeah and those problems are memories
that are tattooed in the brain that are
associated to certain people and things
at certain times and places so the
moment the person wakes up Clean Slate
they start thinking about their problems
they're thinking in the past if you
believe your thoughts have something to
do with your destiny well
it's a possibility that your past is
going to be your future every one of
those problems has an emotion associated
with it so then the moment you start
recalling the problem you start feeling
unhappy now your body's in the past
because thoughts of the language of the
brain and feelings of the language of
the body and how you think and how you
feel creates a state of being so people
reaffirm their identity based on the
past right and it turns out that the
redundancy of doing that
conditioning only requires it requires
an image and an emotion and most people
are unconsciously conditioning their
body into the familiar past into the
known so now if you're in the familiar
past and in the known you're going to
Crave the predictable future right right
that's the known as well and there's
only one place where the unknown exists
and that's the Eternal present moment
that's The Sweet Spot of the generous
present moment so you have you gotta
labor to get that person beyond the
emotions that keep them tacked or
anchored to the past and yes
it takes an effort to do that but if you
keep working with the formula you'll
reach that elegant moment where there's
a liberation of energy and now your body
as the unconscious mind the objective
mind is not believing it's living in the
same past experience 24 hours a day
because you're liberating the body from
that emotional state so you ask the
person why are you so unhappy why are
you so frustrated why are you so
resentful the moment you ask that their
brain is going to associate that emotion
to a past event to a memory to a memory
that's because they have nothing to look
forward to in their future so if you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future it just means to me that you're
more in love with your past than you are
with the future so how do you teach
people to believe in a future that they
can't see or experience with their
senses yet but they've thought about
enough times in their mind that their
brain is literally changed to look like
the event has already occurred the
latest research in Neuroscience says
that's absolutely possible we know that
and how do you teach a person
to select a new possibility in their
future and begin to emotionally Embrace
that future before it's made manifest to
such a degree that their body is their
unconscious mind is believing it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment and they're signaling new
genes in new ways ahead of the
environment now till their body begins
to change to look like the event has
already occurred we've proven that
that's possible now think about this so
the more you think about your desired
future The Joy the Gratitude the uh
the feelings you want to have that are
more positive the more you think about
it as it's as a future thing happening
the more your body shifts now exactly so
your body is believing it's living in
that future reality now in the present
moment now think about this the stronger
the emotion you feel from some condition
in your life the more altered you feel
inside of you the more you narrow your
focus on the cause and the brain freezes
an image and takes a snapshot and that
memory now is embossed in the brain it's
branded in there so then people think
neurologically within the circuits of
those past experiences and they feel
chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and the stronger the
Betrayal the stronger the trauma the
more the body's living in the past right
so then so how you reverse that so now
if you truly got passionate about a
future we've all done this you get a
wild idea in your mind and you start
holding on to that vision and you're
preoccupied with it all of a sudden the
thought in your mind becomes the
experience and you start feeling the the
energy of the future now the stronger
the emotion you feel from that Vision
the more you're going to pay attention
to the picture in your mind and now
you're remembering your future vice
versa the stronger you pay attention to
the feeling of the past pain you're
going to create the pain in this moment
exactly so then so it requires a
coherent brain and we now know that
there's a formula for that and we've got
beautiful research to show that people
can do it they just have to practice and
it requires a coherent heart because
resentment frustration in patience
creates a very incoherent heart yeah and
when that heart becomes incoherent you
stop trusting yourself there's no energy
they get you stop trusting in your
future so then if there's physical
evidence in your brain and body
physical evidence to look like the event
has already occurred it's quite possible
you'll be thinking neurologically within
the circuits of your future and you'll
begin to feel chemically within the
boundaries of that emotion of your
future and how you think and how you
feel is your state of being rule number
five is strive for what you want with
sad Guru someone who has some faith in a
God or in a temple or whatever
who is how simple-minded Faith Works
only for those people who are
simple-minded thinking people people who
are too much thinking for them it never
works a childlike person
who has a simple faith in his God or his
Temple or whatever
he goes to the temple and says Shiva I
want a house I don't know how he
now in his mind there are no negative
thoughts will it happen will it not
happen is it possible is it not possible
these things are completely removed by
the simple Act of Faith
now he believes Shiva will do it for him
and it will happen
so is Shiva going to come and build your
house no I want you to understand God
will not lift his little finger for you
what you refer to as God is the source
of creation
as a Creator he has done a phenomenal
job there's no question about it could
you think of a better creation than this
is it in anybody's imagination to think
anything better than what is there right
now
so as a Creator he has done his job
wonderfully well
but if you want life to happen the way
you want it because right now the very
Crux of your happiness and your
well-being is this
if at all if you're unhappy
the only and only reason why you're
unhappy is life is not happening the way
you think it should happen
that's all it is
so if life is not happening the way you
think it is it should happen you're
unhappy if life happens the way you
think it should happen you are happy
it's as simple as that
so if life has to happen the way you
think it should happen first of all
how you think
with how much Focus you think how much
stability is there in your thought and
how much reverberance is there in the
thought process will determine whether
your thought will become a reality or is
it just an empty thought
or
how you do not create any impediments
for your thought by creating negative
thought process
this possible
is something possible or not possible is
destroying Humanity
what is possible and not possible is not
your business it's Nature's business
your business is just to strive but what
you want
right now you're sitting here
if I ask you two simple questions
I want you to just look at this and
answer this
right now from where you're sitting can
you just fly off you say no
right now from where you're sitting can
you get up and walk you'll say yes
what is the basis of this
why you say no to Flying and yes to
walking because past experience of Life
many times you've gotten up and walked
never did you fly off
or in other words you're using the past
experience of Life as a basis for
deciding whether something is possible
or not possible or in other words you
have decided that what has not happened
till now cannot happen in your life in
future
this is a disgrace to humanity and the
human spirit
what has not happened till now on this
planet can happen tomorrow human beings
are capable of making it happen tomorrow
so what is possible and what is not
possible is not your business
that is Nature's business nature will
decide that you just see what is it that
you really want and strive for that and
if your thought is created in a powerful
way without any negativity without any
negative thoughts Bringing Down the
intensity of the thought process
the first and foremost thing is
you must be clear what is it that you
really want if you do not know what you
want
the question of creating it doesn't
arise
if you look at what you really want
what every human being wants is
he wants to live joyfully he wants to
live peacefully in terms of its
relationships he wants you to be loving
and affectionate or in other words all
that any human being is seeking for is
pleasantness within himself pleasantness
around him
this pleasantness if it happens in our
body we call this help and pleasure
if it happens in our mind we call this
peace and joy if it happens in our
emotion we call this love and compassion
if it happens in our energy we call this
blissfulness and ecstasy
this is all that a human being is
looking for
whether he is going to his office to
work
he wants to make money build a career
build a family he sits in the bar sits
in the temple
he's still looking for the same thing
pleasantness within Pleasant is around
if this is what we want to create I
think it's time we addressed it directly
and commit ourselves to creating it so
you want to create yourself as a
peaceful human being joyful human being
loving human being a pleasant human
being on all levels
and do you also want a world like this a
peaceful world a loving World a joyful
world
no no I want Greenery I want food when
we say a joyful world that means
everything that you want has happened
this is all that you're looking for so
all that you need to do is commit
yourself to creating it
create a peaceful joyful and loving
World both for yourself and everybody
around you
every day in the morning if you start
your day with this simple thought in
your mind that today wherever I go I
will create a peaceful loving and joyful
world
if you fall down 100 times in the day
what does it matter for a committed man
there is no such thing as failure if you
fall down 100 times 100 lessons to be
learned
if you commit yourself like this to
creating what you really care for now
your mind gets organized once your mind
gets organized the way you think is the
way you feel your emotion will get
organized once your thought and emotion
is organized your energies will get
organized in the same direction once
your thought emotion and energies are
organized your very body will get
organized once all these four are
organized in One Direction your ability
to create and manifest what you want is
phenomenal you are the Creator in many
ways angle number six the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
B in the present moment with Eckhart
Tolle the greatest obstacle is probably
uh when meditation comes out of a sense
of lack or neediness so you feel you you
are deprived of something be it money or
uh
relationship or a living situation and
you feel there's a great lack in your
life and you desperately want this to
change
and so you perhaps
use manifestation in a way that is not
likely to work when for example you
use affirmations such as
I want a better job I want a job isn't
as a good income and a life situation in
a nice place and I want this and I want
that
by making these statements
uh you're actually by implication saying
that you don't have it
so yeah also by saying that you are
there's a reverse side to your statement
I want and on the reverse side of the
statement I want there is the statement
I don't have
and I need
and similar things please give me if you
you pray to
maybe God maybe you pray to Jesus maybe
you pray to Buddha they do that in
Buddhist countries maybe you pray to a
saint or whatever it is or you pray to
the universe and say please the universe
please give me this please give me that
that also doesn't work very well if it
works
it could be accidentally who knows but
usually that greatly diminishes your
power of manifestation because it's the
the manifestation practice arises out of
a state of lack or neediness so there's
no powerful manifestation there
The Secret of manifestation is expressed
in one simple statement by Jesus and
that encapsulates
all the books
that have been written on manifestation
and will ever be written on
manifestation is just one simple
sentence it says when you pray for
something believe that you
that it has been given or that you
already have it and then you will
receive it
so the important thing is he doesn't say
believe that you will receive it
it says believe that you have received
it
so there the secret is hiding in that
statement believe that you have received
it
now
the second obstacle manifestation
is yes people understand this statement
but they just cannot get themselves to
believe that they have received
something when they full know only well
that they have not received it so it
almost looks as if you had been asked to
deny reality and you just cannot get
yourself to deny reality so that becomes
the second obstacle to manifestation and
the reason why this is the obstacle is
the people do not understand the
what or what it actually means
what is required for you
to believe that you already have it how
can you overlook external reality and
believe that you already have it and
that the answer to that takes us even
deeper where you have to
be coming to full alignment with the
power of the present moment
and go deep into yourself that is a the
most fundamental practice where you
discover who or what you are beyond the
thinking mind beyond the ego discover
that in essence you are consciousness
and Consciousness is
the unmanifested
life
that is the essence of all life the
source of all life and contains
everything
that could ever be manifested in
external reality I sometimes in a
slightly humorous analogy compare that
realization of Your Inner Essence
with having having found
the cream and all external reality is
the skimmed milk that is uh
um and diluted version of the the cream
which is the essence of all life that is
within you as your
deepest reality so the very foundation
for successful manifestation is finding
who you are in your essence and once
you've found that that already contains
everything that you could wish for on a
Feeling level
so you then whatever you attain then
comes out of the state of fullness not
other state of lack
so when you feel the fullness of life
that is within you
that's Inseparable from the present
moment it's Inseparable from who you are
in the depths of your being
when you find the fullness of life you
virtually have everything already not
nothing that you could obtain could
possibly obtain could improve upon this
realization
so let's say you want to obtain a
great wealth or whatever it is who knows
how will you feel when you have it or
all you want to have some specific
purpose I want to create
the most beautiful thing that helps
millions of others how would you feel if
you've had it right now and this is
exactly how you feel right now when you
get in touch with the essence of Who You
Are
and when you finally obtain it you will
feel no different
so you feel already that fullness
whatever else whatever comes to you in
the external is only a
reflection
a distant reflection of what you have
found within
and so the foundation for
true manifestation of course lies in the
present moment and discover the depths
of the present moment
that's the foundation
if you cannot
come to a into alignment with the
present moment and discover the
secret of the present moment that it's
Inseparable from who you are then no
matter what you achieve either through
hard work or through manifestation
practices will not satisfy you
and your powers of manifestation will
also be greatly diminished
first of all the cause of fear is
ignorance
that is the cause of fear
and so if you follow the ignorance it
doesn't start out as fear
the ignorance starts out in a conscious
level as doubt and worry
um
that's on a conscious level we're doting
or we're worrying then we take whatever
image comes into our consciousness of
the doubt and the worry and we turn it
over to our emotional mind that's what
causes the fear
well that fear then has to be expressed
through the body through the only
instrument it can be expressed through
our physical body it sets up a vibration
known as anxiety
mm-hmm
anxiety is not expressed anxiety becomes
suppressed we suppress it
and the suppression then turns to
depression
which turns to disease which turns to
Decay you see you're talking about a
track a person gets on it's a very
negative track
it's ignorance
don't worry fear
anxiety suppression depression disease
disintegration
now the polar opposite of all that
the opposite of ignorance is knowledge
um
there's only one way to get to knowledge
and that is to study
um
now unfortunately
um School
didn't do the job that it was designed
to do for most of us school should teach
us to love to study
um
not to dread studying and homework and
tests
should teach us to love it because study
leads to the opposite of don't worry
which is understanding
see a study that leads to understanding
we understand how to handle the fear
it's understanding that enables us to
cause us to understand where the fear
starts the understanding then
we want to say what do we understand we
want to understand this whole universe
operates by law
one of the laws is the law of opposite
the opposite of don't worry is
understanding um
now if the don't worry leads to fear
what's understanding leads to
understanding leads to Faith
the faith leads to
expression
well-being an expression
it's not depression it's not suppression
it's not anxiety the faith leads to
well-being
the well-being then is expression
acceleration because we're athies we're
not at there's not disease so you're
dealing with Polar Opposites there's two
different sides to things
and when we understand that
our world starts to change
it's by understanding that we learn how
to deal with these pandemics when they
hit and they will hit there will be
others
there always has been all down through
history if you look back
there's been things like this happen in
the past
and unfortunately the masses are sort of
paralyzed by it consistent action is the
cure-all whatever problem you have
whatever issue you're facing whatever
big life you want to create for yourself
the way to get there is not some giant
short burst of effort it's the daily
consistent grinding action that will
help you accomplish your goals people
look at my channel and
a lot of new people have joined over the
past number of years hey welcome forward
great to have you welcome to believe
Nation it's a positive happy place it's
great to have you here it's an honor to
be a part of your daily routine
if you go and look at my my channel my
main channel in the history it took so
many years guys so many years of just
making content and not seeing any
results
[Music]
I took I forget what the number is it
took five years to get to 9 000
something subscribers and another five
years to get almost two million
subscribers and I was sitting over three
million subscribers Etc
I haven't missed
an upload every single day
for I don't know
eight years
[Music]
something crazy like that
every day
I've made videos through
[Music]
travel I've made videos through elect
electricity electricity outages I made
videos through breaking my neck I made
videos through my tour I made videos
through vacation I made videos I made
videos I made videos I made videos I
made videos I made videos and you can
plan you can prepare you can get ahead
you can you can batch them
but I don't think your goals count until
they're hard
[Music]
it's when it gets hard when when you get
tested that's when you have to show
yourself What You're Made Of
even little things like
I remember filming at my dance studio in
Toronto
and I have my camera guy and my
assistant and we're filming and the
electricity goes out
and then there's a fire alarm
[Music]
they go I guess we can't film like the
first thing that that my camera guy says
is okay well I guess we can't film I
can't film with this like electricity
outage and then
fire alarm
fire alarm
you can't film with that it's like I'm
I'm filming today
so I took my phone it was freezing
outside I took my phone went outside and
just started filming
because videos have to go up
they have to go up
I've I've made videos with my broken
neck
I broke my neck in two spots had a
concussion
and I next week I'm making videos
they weren't as long they weren't as
good
[Music]
I'm wearing a neck brace if you look at
the old videos I'm wearing this giant
neck brace I got this giant scab here on
my forehead because I smashed my head
against the wall
when I fainted and that's how it led to
the concussion broken neck I'm still
making videos
not making videos is not an option
and so if you look at someone like me
who
is introverted is shy who doesn't like
the camera who always thought that
people who are famous had a big ego who
I still don't like being on stage I
still get nervous every single time
[Music]
but I still have a message
and I still want to serve how does
somebody like that
have this kind of Channel well because
of every single day making videos you've
done over 10 000 videos I've done over
10 000 videos that's crazy
not all of them are public
but even just on the main Channel let
alone this channel on the top 10 Channel
all the other channel 10 000 Plus videos
over 12 years
why
how
just a consistent action
I think most people lose because
we overestimate what we can do
in a really
short period of time and underestimate
what we can do in a long period of time
you think by putting in three weeks of
hard work you're gonna crush it
but really if you just stayed on it like
guys you've had ideas you have enough
you have had an idea
that you'd love that you gave up on too
soon that if you just kept doing it this
is an idea that you had maybe three
years ago that if you just found the way
to keep doing it even part-time even on
the side even on the weekends if you
just kept at it you'd be in a different
place right now
something would have happened something
would have paid off
but we're too frustrated to get
something to happen right now and I get
it I'm there too I'm I'm impatient I
want immediate results I want things to
happen I'm putting my best I want this
video right now to be the best one I've
ever done and I put my effort to try to
make that happen and I fully recognize
at the same time that
it's a long game
that you have to keep going
and that it's your purpose you can't
give up on it
most people just quit too soon
just quit too soon
and that's you quitting on your dream
and if it's your dream and you want it
to happen it's a daily consistent
action to make it happen
so how do you do it let me give you some
tactics so that you can not just get
motivated from a message but actually
apply it to your life number one you
have to create a calendar
these videos happen because they're in
my calendar
I'm filming this on a Tuesday Tuesday is
my YouTube day I always film on Tuesday
I block it off in my calendar
I just came back from vacation and on
the Tuesday of my week I was still
making videos people say well still work
on vacation first off it's not work like
I like this this is fun for me this
isn't this isn't oh I have to go make
videos if that was my mindset I would
I'd be out I wouldn't do it anymore
but also if you're on vacation you're
making videos or you're doing a little
bit of work
to spend three hours
of a 24-hour day
doing something
is totally achievable somebody one of
the people that I invested into
yesterday's like how do I take a
vacation on my business
like how do I my wife wants to know how
do I go on vacation and run this
business like you can still you can
either plan ahead and get ahead with all
your clients or you can still do some
work
do you not have personal time are you
going to be around your wife 24 hours a
day does your wife not want to go to the
spa or spend some time on the beach it's
not about the three hours that you spend
working it's about
the other hours at 21 hours you get to
sleep but whatever all the other hours
that you have the day it's about
intentional time most of most people's
life is not intentional most of your
vacation time is not intentional either
if you were to spend 21 hours a day with
your wife
intentionally create an amazing
relationship
[Music]
then the three hours a day you're going
to spend working
as easy as nothing
[Music]
of course you could take time off
[Music]
but you have to put in your calendar
they create a calendar that makes sense
for you schedule in when you're actually
going to make your dreams happen because
otherwise it's a dream I could say I
want to make YouTube videos but if it
was never my calendar guess what it
would never happen and this applies for
life too every uh every afternoon
at 2 30 I spend time with Nina with my
wife
we spend time in the morning I take an
intentional break at 2 30 we go to the
park we take we take the dogs with us
we we stay inside and just be together
if it's raining like we'll spend time
every day every weekday at 2 30 because
I want I wanted to spend more time with
Nina during the week weekends we're
basically all in on on the relationship
but the weekdays can be crazy you know
so we spend time in the morning we spend
time in the evening and I wanted to
spend 2 30. it's 25 minutes together but
intentional 25 minutes that intentional
25 minutes is worth more than three
hours of just sitting in front of a TV
that's not time together
you have a lot more time than you think
just not being intentional that's the
problem if you feel like you got to the
end of the week and you were so busy but
you got nothing done
and everything's falling apart you're
just not intentional with your time
so you schedule it in whatever you want
in a life whatever your dream life looks
like whatever your goals Ambitions
motivations are put in your calendar
two
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
stop letting yourself off the hook
for not following through on your
calendar
I'm a little tired today because we just
came back from our trip I'm a little jet
lagged from coming out from the West
I'm still making videos I'm still videos
have to be made they're going up like
when do you let yourself break
if it's in the calendar it has to happen
videos have to happen today I don't care
if I'm lying in bed I don't care I don't
care if I'm in the hospital I've made
videos from the hospital I don't care
where videos have to come up I don't
care if they're the best videos they're
the best
with what I can make right now
if I'm tired they might be lower than my
standard but it's the best of what I can
make right now if I'm in the hospital
it's definitely lower than what I can
make out of the hospital but I'm going
to make the best of what I can make
right now
be the person who follows through on the
things that you say you're gonna do
because the next time you put something
in your calendar the next time we see
you're gonna get that goal or
do this project you're gonna the next
day wake up and say I'm not there I
can't do that I'm not doing that
you're starting to build the identity
either way of the person who follows
through or the person who doesn't follow
through and every time you say yes to
yourself every time you do it when it's
difficult you start to build up that
identity a little bit more I follow
through I follow through I follow
through so then the next time you put
something in your calendar the next time
comes with a goal you start to believe
that it's actually possible for you to
do it because you're building that
identity of you being the person who
actually follows through
and every time you let yourself off the
hook every time you give yourself a
break every time you say it's okay I'm
not going to do it today every time you
say that
you eat away at that other identity and
start to build a new one
the new identity of the person who
doesn't follow through
you start to believe yourself a little
bit less
the next goal you write down is a little
less credible you don't think you can do
it you're going to realize the next day
that you're not going to follow through
and says it's a very
slippery slope to fall down
so step one is you build a calendar step
two is you become the person who sticks
to your calendar
who follows through on the things that
you say you're going to do that's why
it's important to create a realistic
calendar don't tell me don't tell
yourself you're going to make 100 videos
a day every day
you're going to make a thousand phone
calls a day every day
you're not you're going to write 100
love letters to your wife every day
you're not you're not it's not going to
happen make it a realistic plan for
something you can actually stick to
because again if you just stick to it
guys you will hit your goals
if you stop quitting on yourself if you
stop letting yourself off the hook that
idea you had three years ago should have
already come to Creation because you
just stuck with it just stick with it
step number three so create a calendar
one stick to your calendar number two
three
the environment around you really
matters
videos like this really matters why
create the inspressor to be with you
every morning to give you the Boost to
bring you people like John astraff and
Oprah and Elon Musk and these people who
lift you up who inspire you hopefully
that's the intention every time
join a group like movement makers be a
part of a community be around other
entrepreneurs who are doing things we're
chasing their dreams we're trying to
make their thing happen when you're when
you create that environment and you
start to shift it
it inspires you to want to play bigger
it inspires you to want to stay
consistent when you are feeling at your
lowest low when you're about to quit on
the thing that you said that you want to
do that's in your calendar you see it
you see it today I'm supposed to do that
like I don't want to do that what brings
you out of it
it's the habits it's the environment
it's the routine
watch another video
join our group like movement makers
get a mentor coach
have an accountability buddy
you have to be around the people who
constantly fill your cup who give you
light who lift you up who make you
believe and help you feel like it's
possible when you do those three things
your life will change
create a calendar
that mapped your actions to your
ambitions
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
[Music]
and then be around the people videos
resources environment
that encourages you that lifts you up
and makes you feel like it's possible
the purpose of a goal is not to get it's
not to reach the goal
it's the awareness that you develop as
you go after it
you're learning Who You Are
is becoming aware of who you are
yeah
I was in a seminar years and years ago
and there was this speaker Bill Gove
Bill Gove
was considered the
Frank Sinatra public speakers he was
incredible
he had a handheld mic and he's looking
at the audience and he said
if I want to be free
I've got to be me
not to me I think you think I should be
not to me I think my kids think I should
be not to me I think my wife thinks I
should be if I Want to Be Free I've got
to be me
he said I've got to know who me is I
once read where it said no amount of
reading or memorizing is going to make
you successful it's the understanding
and application of why something happens
you're going to study this
I study it every day
every day
for at least an hour
sometimes more but at least an hour
it's a habit
how about something you do unconsciously
you don't even spend any time thinking
about it you just do it you get dressed
by habit
you shower come wash your hair habit
do you know good habits automatically
transform our life
how do we reshape our self-image to
serve us as opposed to bring us down
well
it's interesting molts
Maxwell malts actually discovered
self-image as we know it today
he was a cosmetic surgeon and he found
if he operated on a person maybe they
had a distasteful scar in their face and
he removed the scar
he said
sometimes there was a phenomenal change
in the person's personality
but he said other times they'd remove
the scar who was very successful no
change in their personality
that led him to postulate that we not
only have this physical image that
reflects back from the mirror we have an
inner image of ourself
it's how we see ourselves right now that
inner image is an idea and that idea is
generally
planted in our little life when we're
infants
and it's planted by virtue of the the
environment that we're surrounded by
how we're raised if a child's raised
with praise they're going to grow up
very confident individuals if a child is
raised with criticism they're going to
grow up very insecure
so you see this image that we have it's
a picture of how we see ourself
but most of us that image was planted by
people it didn't know what the hell was
going on they didn't know the war was
over and they were planting they were
developing a little mind it was a mind
they were shaping it like fresh clay
they didn't understand that it was a kid
they're looking after them we feed him
we'd keep them warm but the hell you
know that's our responsibility no it was
a mind and they were developing that
mind and if they didn't understand what
were they going to put in well they
could give it to the child is the
insecurities that they had themselves
so that was the picture that the kid
grows up of themself
now I grew up very insecure I was born
during a depression when I first went to
school the second world war had just
broken out so everybody's rationed for
everything it was hard times all the men
were away fighting in Europe or South
Pacific there was no men doing nothing
the women that were there were driving
the trucks there were cops they did
everything so it wasn't a whole lot of
time used for developing a little mind
so I just grew up and picked up what I
could I got very insecure it wasn't
until I met a man that gave me this book
and gave me some damn good instruction
and I started to pay attention to who I
was
and I have never stopped being
fascinated with studying me yeah I I am
the most fascinating subject that I've
ever come across
and I have found out that you and I are
exactly the same we only appear to be
different
our physical body looks different we
choose different vocations some earns
more or less than the other
put our potentials exactly the same we
both live in a physical body
we both have these higher mental
faculties we're both Spiritual Beings we
both drawn in Infinite Source of supply
we're the same
so the trick I think for the person that
has insecurities that hasn't got the
strongest image they want they should
find a damn good Mentor
that's what changed my life
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to
activate the power of manifestation
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there if the person's
doing the vision board and they're
saying when I get my new car I get my
new house I get my new relationship then
I'm gonna feel so great well then
they're back to the program waiting for
it to happen